PINKERTON GOES TO HIM, AND SAYS,
WE GOT TO GET YOU THE [bleep]
OUT OF HERE
A DAY BEFORE THEY'RE
GONNA KILL YOU, SO--
HE TOOK OFF HIS LITTLE
POP-TART HAT,
OR WHATEVER THAT WAS.
UH, WHAT WAS IT CALLED?
A POP--POPEYE, POPEYE--
IT WAS A CALLED A...
HIS HAT, IT WAS A STOVEPIPE.
LINCOLN SAYS, SORRY, STOVEPIPE.
I GOT TO BE INCOGNITO.
I'LL SEE YOU SOON.
THEY SNEAK HIM OUT TO THE TRAIN.
PEOPLE CAN SEE HIM,
BUT THEY DON'T KNOW IT'S HIM,
BECAUSE HE'S WEARING A BEANIE
AND A SHAWL.
KATE WARNE IS LIKE,
I NEED TO GET MY INVALID BROTHER
INTO THE TRAIN.
THEY GET ON THE TRAIN.
"ZU-DI-DI-DOO, DI-DI-DOO."
LINCOLN IS ON A TRAIN INTO D.C.
TO BECOME THE PRESIDENT.
SO PINKERTON HAD TO GET LINCOLN
THROUGH BALTIMORE EARLY
TO GET TO D.C.
WITHOUT BEING KILLED,
BECAUSE THERE ARE ASSASSINS
IN BALTIMORE
WAITING FOR LINCOLN TO SHOW UP
AT, LIKE, NOON.
THEY GET TO PRESIDENT STATION,
BALTIMORE, MARYLAND,
AT 3:30 IN THE MORNING.
AND THE CONDUCTOR'S LIKE,
WE HAVE TO STOP,
BECAUSE THERE'S A SOUND
ORDINANCE.
PINKERTON'S LIKE,
WHAT THE [bleep]?
THERE'S A [bleep]
SOUND ORDINANCE?
WHAT THE [bleep]
AM I GONNA DO?
OKAY.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT WE'LL DO.
WE'LL GET SOME [bleep] HORSES.
[laughs]
SO THEY HOOK UP THIS TRAIN CAR
TO HORSES,
AND DRAG THE TRAIN CAR ON
THE TRACKS THROUGH BALTIMORE.
THEY GET TO CAMDEN STREET
STATION,
WHERE THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO PICK UP
THE WASHINGTON-BOUND TRAIN.
NO TRAIN.
TRAIN'S LATE.
SO THEY SAT THERE.
IT'S BASICALLY
ASSASSINS EVERYWHERE.
AND THEY COULD HEAR
PEOPLE SAYING,
THIS [bleep] LINCOLN
IS A PIECE OF [bleep].
THE SOUTH WILL RISE.
PINKERTON'S LIKE,
IF THESE GUYS FIND OUT
THAT WE'RE IN HERE
WITH LINCOLN, WE'RE DEAD.
WE'RE ALL OF US DEAD.
YOU HOLD ON TO YOUR PANTIES.
[laughing]
NO, HE WOULD NOT HAVE--
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
THE WASHINGTON-BOUND TRAIN
FINALLY SHOWS UP.